hello and welcome to this session
the first of this day dedicated
to the g suite of this day of
insights
I am luca politi account manager of
google cloud in particular for the
regions of piedmont and emilia romagna
so I also see familiar faces among you
the title of  this session is a bit
provocatively smart working co
working smart because although this
word the smart four kings is
probably used and even a little too
maybe abused in some cases we at
google believe that there really is a
way to work
smarter than to work  better and why
not maybe even to work less and here I
already see you more interesting maybe the
second let's say the subtitle is that
of change management success stories
precisely because we will also have the pleasure
and honor of having here on stage in the
second part of this  this tops
some of the companies we have
worked with best in the last time that
have done PR  extremely
innovative objects such as fontana gruppo and
noberasco
but what is the main objective of
your company
probably the answer varies in a
range of companies and can range
from maximizing turnover to
optimizing internal processes
expand geographically
internationally wherever you are
wherever whatever the answer is this
question
this is what we call
this last objective the max velocity and
what separates you from this max velocity
well in the metaphor we have here
we say on the left on your
left we have a laser optimist
I am not very expert at  sailing boat in
which we have a crew of 4 5 people
in which, however, it is only a single
person to carry on the implications
with probably modest results
on the other hand we have instead a hydro
file therefore a new paradigm
for competition boats in which more  whether or not
we have the same number of people as the
crew  but in which each person
works and collaborates at the same time in
real time as part of a gear
where everyone is collaborating together
to obtain what is the best
speed in this very physical sense
that the boat can have good this is
just what the  agi suite wants to
do for companies that is to make them
collaborative and bring them
to their maximum potential
well although most of
you in your companies do not think they are
at the level of the optimist and laser even if
some in my experience have seen them
that maybe they do not even reach more
than anything else they are on a kayak or a shi bar
as they say by me in pavia
probably few of you can
honestly say that you are really at
what their maximum
potential
here is what we are
looking for  to help you and typically
many of you many of your companies
and especially the people
within your companies probably have
already begun in part this path
many work forcibly we
always say always from more places from the train
from the plane you work from multiple devices
because one often finds himself having to
work reading e-mails reading
documents files from his mobile phone
from a tablet  change computer and
the end user expects the same from
his mobile phone
just as he is accustomed to in the consumer world
from what he expects from the
desktop and so let's say what
people typically expect and
what companies try to
achieve is this a  way and a
corporate world in which we work we collaborate
together we work on mobile always
connected
but unfortunately many times this and that
the reality towards which we find ourselves then
actually colliding this is one
of our large American customers who by
implementing what was the  latest
greatest so
better than the old let's say
traditional software vendor that you can even
imagine who is  a had proposed to him
in reality they had found themselves
simply having what was a
solution with a re-design of the product
according to the new paradigms of
modern design that change from year to year but
little actually had changed there
was not even a process behind it
of change management it is extremely
important that we always push
with our partners precisely to change
what is the way of working from an
individualistic way to a
collaborative way of productivity
well if 30 years ago we worked like this or
at least so they tell me
that is it was created  on a sheet of paper if
they shared it, annotations were added
and then it was consolidated in
a process that actually continued
nowadays the process exactly the
same the tools have changed but
maybe somebody recognizes some network here too
but the process exactly the
same  indeed in some cases we have even
worsened what was the
situation before because we have i  The problem
of increasingly large attachments attachments
to spreadsheet presentations
which are difficult to send and
for disputes very difficult to manage as
well as potentially very expensive and
in the versions I imagine that any of
you,
any person of you who has
prepared presentations has had to
face let's face the
problem of having version 1 2 3
final final do not touch latest
version please do not touch
anything anymore and there is no single source of
truth than what
the final version of the presentation
here is with  agi street instead we
think that there is a better and
different way of being able to collaborate more openly
where the star silo of the various
departments collapse where with a
click
I can enter a
document and find myself
collaborating on the  same on the same
document from multiple devices from
wherever I am and with a click
I can start a video  or conference
in which all my colleagues are inside
wherever they are
close colleagues who are partners who
are companies that do not even
need to download a plug in
to be able to collaborate and
always have my entire desk at my disposal.
my files precisely
wherever I am from a customer
who is around that we are having me
or precisely that he is
traveling as we have seen before
this is precisely what agi street
helps people to achieve helps
companies to achieve  all in a
solution that is unique and complete
there is no need also from the point of view of the
sensing of how it is presented
then of how it can actually be bought
companies is
extremely simple there are
various pulls depending on what you
want  get and one has
all the tools available
starting from those of that help to
connect my people central point
that he has  we have seen before and that in
the next session you will see in
detail that of the road map of the g
suite then moving on to what are the
files and the suite for creating
real documents where I can go to
collaborate on the same within
the same document  create
corporate intranets by moving the
jambor universe of the
interactive whiteboard connected to hangouts and
then switching to the maker you saw in the
keynote keep and then moving on to
what is the platform that must be at the
base of everything, i.e. drive to archive
all this all these files  and
what is a bit the google now of my
productive working suite that google
cloud search without forgetting
obviously all the control part
that is essential for companies to
have a control over what
are their company data
well kt safely and absolutely
compliant
here and before getting on stage
those who are in my opinion the
most important point  interesting about this speech
so our customers who will
tell us
what their experience has been with adopting these
tools
I also wanted to leave you with this
link that you see
at the top right that g.co slash
transformation gallery this is a
collection that we have  done and is
constantly evolving so we continue
to update where there are a whole
series of examples and use cases of
real companies or processes that
are made divided by verticals
divided by departments from which each
company can take inspiration from  Another
note is the Fontana group and even
in one of these
international cases mentioned in
our transformation gallery so I
absolutely invite you to go and
take a look at it
but I would say not to waste any more time and
let those who are on stage get on stage.
our customers to
make a small roundtable a lot
we say among ourselves what in
english who  they love a firework
let's say if it ends or exactly
and then I call on the
stage matteo ceccarini and simone
paravicini of the fontana group fontana group
small family business that has
grown to become a company of
4,300 people in Brianza with seriousness
now throughout the  world and leader in the
sector of
bolt tightening so matteo and simone please
come on stage maybe let's put
the stools
less put
on
a company that makes the best
dried fruit I've ever tried but
let's say that it also supplies what
are our mike rockitchen in google
in the offices if the peaks already seen
calls on the stage silvia siri di
noverasco another
Italian family company that has grown enormously
in the  last time
I take it too in the hair is
fine
move again
in place and go down  iamo on the other hand
very well then I would start precisely in
this conversation that is now between
friends since we see each other more and more
often all these events
perhaps asking you first about fountains and then later
to silvia di noberasco to ask you
what it was  not only the history
of your company
and what then led your
company to undertake this
dg suite project so what was the
ska factor that gave rise to this
innovation yield in what
the project you
embarked on
then consists in a few words  let's say that as
Gruppo Fontana said at the beginning,
a company born from a family point of view
and therefore owner like all the
companies of the sun has then become a
multinational of 4,500 employees
let's say that thanks to the latest
acquisitions and above all to the American market
we have found  the inspiration to create
this great collaboration
within our
family because in high  rnative we would
have had to make investments on connections
that they would then have and therefore on
infrastructures necessary for the
connection so what they
decided to do was to
evaluate products on the google market.
first showed you
the way to collaborate
all together on the same documents
the fact of having a
common e-mail system and the possibility of
also developing processes on
the google platform so let's say this
were some of the triggering events
of this of this  project and then
we started in May 2015 with a whole
feasibility study supported by
grafts that followed us throughout
the journey where we started to be
the so-called guy to see if the
benefits of this investment
actually also had an economic return
so we  analyzed all the
hardw part  are that there was behind
any connections and we understood
that it could be done and then we
started in May 2015 and went
live globally so on 4000
users in January 2016
silvia in your case a
similar experience starting from the same let's say  to the
same concepts or something different
maybe to be noted about theirs compared
to their experience
let's say that the google project
was more than anything else a project for the
teams but a project of cultural change
so it was born from the need to
strengthen what it was
collaboration within the company and
therefore a collaboration of people,
however, because noberasco where it is
a historic company was born in 1908
so it really has a very
important history is a very innovative company
so let's say it often dedicates itself no to
new projects  new solutions and in
any case this great innovation
of his ability to innovate the capacity to
double the turnover in five years  i
therefore this growth
clearly had to be managed and
in the last five years even the very
theme of the collaboration of the
internal collaboration of the company was
really an important issue so
this collaboration project was carried out
and google was precisely the
tool that the company  seen as a
tool that could really make a
difference to help
the company in this let's say exactly the
flexibility and simplicity that google
gives in giving
proactive useful tools to the collaboration
you had set
goals
when you embarked on this project
and are  have been achieved it is
absolutely thanks to the friends of next
we were able to say to extend the
entire google suite within the
company and immediately starting from the bottom
because the first step was that of
a bit here queen so to have
all those adopted  all those that were
google tools from google sheets
docume  nti
for their own active collaboration
on what were let's say the documents that
generated most of the
emails and revisions clear with word
and excel to be able to collaborate on
documents that were not done
simply they did the revision 1
is attached go the email  it was sent perhaps
with a screenshot of the cell
of the box that you wanted to comment and
clearly this generated
incredible quantities of emails with google
we pushed from the bottom let's say
transform all these documents into
leaves and
google documents and to collaborate
directly on the file so the first
let's say the first  the result that we have
been able to see with hand but the users
themselves is that of a reduction of mails
but as an effect in truth the advantage
was precisely the collaboration because
everything is easier
that is you do not have to move go attach
a file to an email go to even
just  make a chain of
sant'antonio of the mails to understand if
there is a  open window to everyone for a
meeting no to easy are go to
compare calendars with google
calendar and in a moment you will find the
window to be able to organize a
meeting or a call conference with up to
ten people so
collaboration was a goal achieved yes
I think  I believe that simplicity
is always one of the pillars that is
always highlighted by the agi street
and maybe matteo asking the same
question you had
set goals
when you started the project you
a few years before
you reached them yes then i  our
objectives were of two types
tactical and strategic objectives our
dimensions have grown a lot
during 2014 and therefore we have
practically doubled both the revenues
and the number of employees and from a tactical point of
view we had two different
e-mail systems in emea and
in  north america which are then the
most important regions for us
this has us  led to make a
technological choice and then go to
join the mail systems to North
American Europeans and also make a
transition to the cloud
because one of our
main objectives was to digitize the
collaboration process that cannot fail to
pass through a digitization
of e-mails and  of the documents therefore this
tactical objective which was to replace
let's say outlook and lotus was not
reached with google all ages suite is
instead from a strategic point of view
what mattered a lot to us was also
trying to give
a change also from a cultural point of view
to our  people
the fact of having so many
different nationalities within the group who
speak different languages working different time zones
led u
to look for a tool
hat could allow us to colla
orate in real time with every instr
ment in every part of the world and this
for us it was very strategic
because before we had great
difficulties  simply to find us to
hold meetings or even to
exchange very simple documents
such as excel files so we have
achieved both the short-term tactical objectives
so having a single system that is the
same for everyone in the cloud is a
strategic level to work in a
shared way in everything  the world and I have
to tell me personally one of the things
that struck me the most when I
heard the
person who dealt with
digital transformation in ovs like you talk about another
of our customers
was the fact that he was talking about Marco
grieco told how they had
implemented an email solution
this was what
they started from as a preconception and
had reduced the number of emails from
I don't remember 45 million exactly
half you have seen something similar
precisely because you move from what
it is  the typical chain of sant'antonio
towards new simpler ways of chat of
commen of commen  ti in single documents
or not this yes we have noticed we have
seen that with the sharing of
documents people
use more this these features
that are provided within the g
suite we even say that
we have forced our hand a little too
users by removing some
microsoft applications then we
removed all the power point and
word parts and let's say we led them by the
hand to use the tools and
suites it is clear that with all the
initiatives we have within a
company that counts this  number of
employees
the fact of being able to work on a single
version of being able to comment on each of the
different aspects of the project has
allowed us to significantly reduce emails
the fact of using chats but not only
we are also very google mit therefore
we do not have systems of  videoconference
we only use that one only
because to
be able to organize a videoconference it is
enough to put a pac man  thing calendar
and therefore everyone has the link to be able to
connect then being google on
each device
we have people who are connected
from all over the world so whether it is
through smartphones rather than
tablets or PCs or rooms equipped with the
chromebook for meeting we are always
therefore connected despite the different
time zones we all work around a table
so let's say that we have seen many
benefits especially us side and we
have seen the documents in the
shared areas that have disappeared therefore
storage occupation that is reset
everything is in the cloud and above all the
revisions of the  documents that there is one
on which you can go and see
all the chronology of the interventions
made by people who can
restore the version you want is
like this if I remember correctly you too have
seen in a project a
drastic reduction in what it was  the time
it was done before let's say
it was done before and the time it was done before
after the implementation of the gis
twitter it was possible I do not remember I
do not know if I remember correctly it was that of
customer satisfaction yes
the analysis of the marine company climate
exact yes it is however
then in noberasco it has always been a
very felt theme, let's say that of the
sense of belonging  to
the company the attachment to the shirt and therefore every
two years this questionnaire is done
this questionnaire is organized
to understand precisely the degree of
satisfaction of our employees
and therefore two years ago we had done
as usual the analysis of the climate
through normal  world then then
collected those who had
been the interviews and more or less it took
us a week here
this year we did it instead with the
google modules and we managed in
practically just the time to be able to
interview the three shifts  of
work of the production and then precisely
at the end as we closed we
had already immediately the results  tati because it is
all automatic so really in a
time that is to tell her to do it dearly come out
is another very nice project that
both companies have in common a bit the
one on blue collars no so
not only on the more polite productive part, let's
say the company
but also on what the workers part
and the more that work more in the factories
maybe you want to tell us something I
don't know maybe three games reborn daughter yes
then we have extended the g suite
also blue collar
always with this in mind no to reduce the
distance between  management
and ownership are operational and therefore we have extended
this suite and blue collar and
together with the creation of the
corporate intranet to which all blue collars
can connect go and see
all the innovations
open projects all the news related to  company
and where every employee can take an
active part in
going to tell what
those who are, let's say they were
objectives achieved by the department those
that are the innovations even at the simplest level of
their own and also of a
simple production logistic department
and always in this company internet
to involve them more and more we have
created what the ideas box
where every employee can go
one his idea or what is his
idea of to improve let's
say anything in the context of hi
work indeed this
s also rewarded if applied is re
arded directly by his exact
who is always very careful precisely to tr
to motivate the staff
15  suite has really given us a hand in
this then in the former there is always a
lot of support so we were also able to
spread it right from the basics here are
excellent in your case maybe matteo in
our case we have two experiences
an experience here also North American one
experience  which are
slightly different in Europe we are
planning to bring to the factory  The agi
suite on the workstations, let's say shared,
as kiosks that allow
employees, our employees,
and factory operators who do not
have access to an advanced company tool
to be able to query
the company intranet, the company website through these totems
and receive
information on how the
company is evolving and on the main
news that are published
internally another theme that we are
trying to understand
and that
we have already verified from a labor law point of view
can also be done safely in
Italy and bring your own device
therefore we are doing pious yes to
allow those who do not have a company mobile phone
to be able to bring their
mobile phone and using and roll for
work to divide that part of the
telephone that is personal from the
company data side in order to
completely segregate the information and
also give  operators the possibility of
having a box never  The company, on the other hand,
in North America we are more focused
on the theme of hunger on the shop floor and
therefore of integration with the
factory since we have them
some tools by amy baits are not
very advanced we have our
American colleagues have created a system based
on today  on google.it then on
google spreads to collect
production data and have them directly in the
cloud and then interrogate them with
reporting tools such as data study
for example these are more or less the
two experiences we are doing on
blue collars and  simone maybe it can be said
that the google project and
the introduction of the g suite at
the time
this is a bit of this change of
mentality may also have been one
of the points that perhaps
even resulted in a wider innovation
at  internal company and that has
led more and more to the world of the
cloud if I'm not mistaken because then from there
we say a series of other
pro  maybe adjacent jets
of which I don't know if you want to tell us
something but yes let's say that what
we did was clearly
to exploit the google platform
we have transferred some
non-core processes to google
so let's say that they do not have a
direct impact on the business by
exploiting precisely  those that are
data studio functionalities rather
than workflows and now we are
also trying to bring some processes instead
of business such as the vendor rating or as
you showed before some
processes related to
the world and randy because because the
tool lends itself because  the
open tool and then
let's say we started this journey
clearly to find the solutions to
our
needs we also make use of a
support program always with in the
east from where we are explained from
week to week what are
the possibilities that it  tool offers and
therefore we keep up to date and
what it does  mo also is to
use the methodology the methodology
already then in the face of the requirements that
we are unable to collect from
our users go and check what
we can go to create on google and
then
create mockups that we then show
to our users and  if we say it like this
there is the correspondence between supply and demand, it
means the tool is
released into production and then we
try to evolve so we are
fully marrying the google
part with the cloud part and this not only with gulan
and with  other tools in fact today we
also talk about multi cloud but let's say
that one of the pillars remains right
before your google clear silvia
what the future has in store I know that there is
a project with data studio to
partially replace sharepoint there  it is
something else about which to tell
his people as simone told us
we are also trying to migrate all
those processes, above all precisely
partend  or from the no cores bring them to
the google platform
we too started with everything
that is the new product development process
so everything you
make it because clearly these processes
have as we say criticality we say
timeliness no to be able to get to the
bottom